so Matthew and Michelle from your point
of view from assembling all of these
moving parts including assembling a cast
that is a stellar cast but you want a
repertory sense where everybody kind of
occupies the same level of performance
and importance in the role how did you
bring on all those people and said yeah
you're all gonna work essentially at the
same pitch you know and you can fight
over billing the way you want to well it
when I came onto the project it was just
and we were in post on LBJ and there was
this great script obviously Rob was
directing woody was attached but he'd
always kind of been attached since we're
making LBJ and wanted to be a part of
this and when we basically decided to go
for it the script attracted an
incredible cast I mean you know it was
literally within four or five weeks we
had basically cast this put together an
incredible cast it was at word-of-mouth
and people came to you or did you have
you mentioned Rob's magic name no no I
made yeah I call these I call these
people up I mean that's how you do it
you know they you call them up and you
say I got something here and here's
what's interesting about this the actors
will work for virtually nothing if
there's something they feel it's it's
worthwhile and they that that they can
be part of and that was this was a
pretty easy sell to to every every one
of these actors the only thing I can
tell you and I literally I mean Tommy
Lee Jones jumped on Jessica Biel James
Marsden Milla Jovovich
and initially one of the first person I
called was Alec Baldwin and he agreed to
play the part that I wound up playing
and the reason he's not there is and we
rearranged an entire schedule to
accommodate Alec so that he could leave
on Fridays to go up and shoot I mean to
be on Saturday Night Live you know with
the doing Trump
and we have been shooting for a week and
we were shooting with woody and Tommy
leader we had shot and then on a
shooting around the Alec role well he
hadn't yet come in yeah he hadn't yet he
was scheduled to come in cuz you know
Tommy Lee Jones has a whole bunch of
stuff with richard schiff in a in a
restaurant you know we had shot other
things when we gonna get into the
newsroom that we're gonna be there for
eight days and that's when he was going
to start coming so on a Saturday he was
supposed to shoot Monday that Monday
Saturday I get a call from the agent
saying he's not doing it he quits he's
out he's dropped out I said oh my god
this is like insanity you know we've
been shooting for a whole week and I
don't know what to do i and so Michelle
says why don't you play the part and I
good producing yeah I figured while I'm
available because I know I will work
cheap said okay and then you know we we
went ahead with it and I don't really
like it because I don't like it's a
split kind of a split focus but she gave
me the one the one bit of direction that
because I'm playing this guy John
Walcott you know she said just try to be
less Jewish if you can how'd that work
for you and I would yeah well I tried I
don't know I I know I'm born in the
Bronx and I and I am Jewish I don't know
how that works
Michelle you've seen him of course
worked through so many he knows I'm
Jewish knows we've seen me so how does -
ah can all play differently I mean it
was how was his level of interest
excitement engagement did it compare to
some other projects that he had done
this is something really personal for
him totally he's very involved in this
you know in this topic and he you know
we were obsessed with this it was like
it was very obvious to us that they were
lying and there was no reason to go to
war and we protested against it and we
saw it around the world and for some
reason every you know news outlet and
you know most Americans did not believe
it
I don't still to this day I understand
what happened I think they got caught up
in the patriotism and they didn't we
were shocked by you know by 9/11 was
interesting because we played this film
the first time we played it we in in
Europe in Zurich it's in Switzerland
standing ovation standing ovation
because every workplace in the world
gets what happened here and like I say
it was like I felt like I was a parent
wait a minute don't you wait what do you
you know how can this be happening how
can this be happening
and it happened in Vietnam - so the
truth is important and but every single
review that is negative about this is
reporters who seem to not be able to
deal with the guilt of not having dealt
with this properly you know they it's
their failings that they're prepared
yeah it has to be their failings if
you're a journalist and you're and
you're writing got to tell you now
there's a lot of great journalism right
now trying to get to the truth of what's
happening with Russia and in this
country we were invaded there's no
question about it we were attacked we're
invaded and you have a lot of people you
know pussyfooting around the new york
times which had to apologize for their
coverage of the Iraq war because they
didn't do their due diligence they
because it's like the character that I
play in the movie goods what is the only
thing you have to if the government says
something there's only one question you
have to ask is it true is it true that's
your only job as a journalist find out
the truth because every single
administration you know puts out
propaganda they do it because they're
trying to sell a policy or a rationale
go to war but you've got to pin them
down especially when war is involved now
something even more serious is involved
which is whether or not the democracy
survives it's under attack here and all
around the world so it will not survive
unless the unless the press is and they
have a big big head wind right now huge
head wind
they've got 40% of the country being fed
total lies by essentially state-run
media which we've never had in America
where we have a administration backed up
by state-run media Fox and Breitbart and
Sinclair and Alex Jones that's a big
tough thing but if you remember during
the campaign the New York Times had a
had a headline saying there's absolutely
no connection between the Trump campaign
and the Russians that was right there in
the middle of the campaign and everybody
shut down and this is after we heard
that the Russians had hacked us now the
Navy there wasn't maybe there would be
but they didn't know that and they
printed that anyway and I you know those
are the kinds of things that send people
off on the wrong on the wrong track we
need the truth now more than ever we
really need the truth otherwise we're
not gonna survive how did you deal with
talking to the reporters and the editor
of the bureau chief as you construct of
this as you did your research because
there were a couple of lines like Intel
cherry-picking they grab a piece of [ __ ]
paint it red and stick it in a Shirley
Temple which made me laugh out loud are
these the things that you're getting
from the reporters from what happened to
them or is this the script using what
they told you to forward the story I try
to keep as close to what actually
happened as possible and these guys were
really funny guys so they gave us a lot
of great lines I know Warren's lying
about are you a Republican or a Democrat
seems to get one of the biggest laughs
and that's what he said luckily he's a
really shy guy so luckily I interviewed
his wife as well but yeah yeah looking
back at all the president's men that was
definitely a model as well as spotlight
and I was struck by a couple differences
one is that in the story here you're
used to seeing the two young reporters
who are pushing their story pushing
their story and their editor is saying
you know you haven't got it yet
and in this case it was reversed it was
these two young guys were doubting
themselves and their their editor was
trying to tell them that to believe in
themselves so that was nice that it was
a little different story arc and then
the other thing that struck me is you're
very used to seeing reporters going
after sources and sources don't want to
talk you know or they're a little cagey
and they say follow the money but they
won't tell you
anything beyond that and here sources
wanted to talk and there were a lot of
what you'd call leaks and you realize
that when good people in the government
are seeing something that they think is
bad they want to tell people and they
need people who will listen so
unfortunately that's not as great for
drama when sources are willing to give
up the information rather easily but
Richard Schiff goes into that that
restaurant and he wants that story told
so and Matthew from your point of view
because there is a legacy at heritage of
newspaper movies what were you looking
for in this one in particular in the
script and the approach that would make
it stand out as it does well I mean a
couple of the other Brooke you know
films you talk about all the President's
Men and spotlight that's really pointing
to and celebrating the success of
journalism as a whole there wasn't a
truth to be known and these guys dug it
up the the in this case its points out a
huge failing of journalism across the
board except for four people and the
fact that we went to war on a lie like
this it's it's it's I mean it's
breathtaking and when you look at this
and you you somehow get dulled to the
events that happen but I mean if you
cast your mind back it's amazing that it
happened so you know it was an
incredible story from all of our
perspectives and one that I really
thought needed to be told what do you
want people to come away from this film
thinking or maybe more importantly doing
well what I want L you what I want ya
vote is the big thing this is this is
the this is a strange time first of all
to understand the importance of the
press and to find yeah it takes a lot
more work to be a citizen in this
country now than it ever has before
because there's so much information
being flung at you find places that you
know that you know art are honest and
then read a couple of different things
to really understand what is true and
what's not true and at the end of it you
have to vote because here's the thing
the Democrat and by the way I've got a
lot of good Republican friends really
good for but that are very principled
and very intelligent and very caring
about this country and
they will tell you if you want to save
the country right now you have to vote
for Democrats and they will vote for
Democrats that doesn't mean that they
agree with the ideology of Democrats but
there's something that supersedes all
that and that is democracy democracy
right now there's no checks and balances
the press is under attack
the rule of law is under attack and the
president is in bed with all the old
thorns around the world he's trashing
our allies we're in a very strange place
so even though Democrats are the vast
majority in this country have been for a
long time we don't vote and and now
we're gonna have to vote even more we
won we won the last election by three
million votes and we don't have an
electoral college but this is the
midterms and electoral college doesn't
come into play we're facing headwinds of
gerrymandering voter suppression and
Russian influence which is playing out
right now as we're as we're doing so we
have to win by an enormous amount just
to take back the house so that we can
have hearings and we can start holding
the president accountable so that's what
we have to do that's what has to happen
please thank the panel thank